hi everyone I hope that you're enjoying
my let's play until dawn we're up to pop
twelve on my youtube channel right now
and I screwed up the original recording
of this one so I'm having to rerecord it
right now I've tried this three times
and every single time I screw up some
kind of coordination in it that means
basically that I have to start the whole
chapter five again every single time to
try and do it again so I have written
down notes of exactly what I did at this
part of the game so I can do it exactly
the same so we don't screw it up
and because mom is currently helping me
pack to move to America I have my sister
here for this one she hasn't actually
she's seen us play with to the game but
she hasn't actually seen this pot which
is a pretty creepy part of the game so
my code would be cool anyway so let's do
it and not screw it up this time okay oh
is that the crazy guy it's been very
common spoil things you know so what you
have seen is the hand up of what this
video is
this pot is really cool
definitely something just watching you
that Bob that's [ __ ] wait
okay seriously that is a falter
it's really nice why wouldn't she dress
though you'll see left inside
this kids like slowly smiling a faint
silent right now inside
well I'm sure yeah
yeah
you want to do well I feel like like
bell tower arrest
it's not a great time to pull up son hey
everything's on track so far
oh yeah he's like oh nice try Alaska too
stuffy yeah you like Stas group winerack
like it was about nine
wherever she is right now it's for a
suck tongue yeah this place is so
amazing it's crazy like a mansion or
notes yeah I think it's a mansion that's
really like built on me of a really long
period of time that believes renovations
is this helmet yes finally oh my God
look because every time I replay it she
keeps getting like this she keeps
thinking catching it once because I'm
here to control at one time because I
made a different decision to the first
time they made an iPhone it was the same
one and oh my god it's infuriating it's
done it's done yeah yes it did it went
perfectly
psychiatrist dimension doesn't have some
kind at Christmas free you just keep it
a room and what are we paying you can do
psychiatry like I repeat [ __ ] when I
book I mentioned I expect every second
every room just saying what these kids
need psychiatrist
let me get old gonna need just because
of all observations that have happened
I'll just cut it a mom she gets [ __ ]
chases quite right she could really make
a lot of money with that town yeah one
of those I feel like it's probably about
sorry but then the camera and drying is
something I would be really stretchy
you're like yeah rashes let's not let's
not like a little bit that [ __ ] joint
oh [ __ ] you